I was born into war right into it people  think they understand thing but they  have no concept of it what's the most  pain you've ever felt maybe the gun that  leaves you more machine man  wait no stop what in the actual ass bail  what why why are the visual effects not  done it's a metal arm it's not like  we're trying to remove a mustache oh  [ __ ] it I'll do it myself  I'm cable and I'm from the future  and I like blowing [ __ ] up oh no sheriff  Deadpool you know you're a lot taller in  the shut up you little [ __ ] take this  regeneration powers activate that's not  something simple I got the stones to  help you fighting they're done already  oh wow that was unrealistic we fast okay  in it  your time's up you dumb [ __ ] well that's  just lazy writing  [Music]  [Music]